[Music]
thank you
one of the more enigmatic even puzzling
characters in Philip K Dick's the man in
the High Castle is this person that
portrays himself at first as an Italian
truck driver and War veteran Joe
kennedella and all of his interactions
are well except for the very first
engagements with Julianna Frank one of
the main characters and we get to see
who he actually is not only through her
eyes but through the revelations that he
makes to her but it's quite interesting
because he will over the course of their
discussions make a lot of quite
impassioned declarations to her about
who he is and how he relates to her
which all turn out to be false and we
could say is he just really good at his
job as a Nazi agent or does he really
believe some of this stuff until he
doesn't believe it and there isn't a
clear answer to this in the work I would
say
so we we encounter him first when
Juliana is getting herself something to
eat at this lunch counter and you know
she's looking at Tasty Charlie's broiled
hamburgers reading the menu and there
are these two truck drivers that come in
and we we see this they took pleasure in
noticing how attractive she was even
lacking the fry cook's kidding she would
have found the truck driver scrutinizing
her the months of Act of Judo had given
her unusual muscle tone she knew how
well she held herself and what it did
for her
for her figure and the fry cook warns
the truck driver stay away from from her
she'll throw you on her can and she
talks to them and she says where are you
two from and they both say Missouri and
she says are you from the United States
I am the older man said Philadelphia got
three kids there the oldest is 11 and
then she says is it easy to get a good
job back there and on the younger truck
driver this is Joe says sure if you have
the right color skin he himself had a
dark brooding face with curly black hair
his expression had become set and bitter
he's a the older man said this is a
derogatory term that's been used for
Italians for a very long time and then
Juliana says well didn't Italy win the
war
she smiled at the Young truck driver but
he did not smile back instead his somber
eyes glowed even more intensely suddenly
he turned away I'm sorry she thought but
she said nothing I can't save you or
anyone else from being dark and then she
asked the truck driver are you going
back on the road tonight and he says
tomorrow and and she says well if you're
not happy with the U.S why don't you
cross over permanently I've been living
in the Rockies for a long time and it's
not bad I lived on the coast in San
Francisco they have the skin thing there
too
glancing briefly at her as he sat
hunched at the counter the young Italian
said now this is very revelatory of his
mindset at the beginning
Lady it's bad enough to have to spend
one day or one night in a town like this
live here Christ if I could get any
other kind of job and not have to be on
the road eating my meals in places like
this and then the older truck driver
says Joe you're a snob and Juliana says
you know you could live in Denver it's
nicer up there and so they're you know
talking back and forth then about the
war and uh you know the the Nazis and
and the Japanese and Judaism and then we
find something else interesting so this
is a little bit later in that third
chapter
no one noticed her Juliana except the
young Italian truck driver his dark eyes
were fixed on her Joe his name was what
Joe what uh she wandered closer to him
now she saw that he was not as young as
she had thought hard to tell so there's
something special about him she's going
to decide the intensity all around him
Disturbed her judgment continually he
drew his hand through his hair combing
it back with crooked rigid fingers
there's something special about this man
she thought he breathes death
it upset her and yet attracted her
and then uh basically there's there's a
hookup right and there's some exchange
of uh commodity Goods nylons stockings
right this is sort of an old tired thing
and she agrees to drive him to his Motel
as it turns out that's not what they
actually do they go back to her place
now there's a lot going on there being
foreshadowed in this first chapter but
then we pick it up in chapter six
Juliana goes out does some shopping
comes back finds him still in bed right
laying where she'd left him in the
center of the bed on his stomach his
arm's dangling he was still asleep no
she thought he he can't still be here
the truck's gone did he miss it
obviously and then she asks did he
intend to miss it that's what I wonder
and then we get this interesting
reflection about their sexual relations
What A peculiar man he'd been so active
with her going on almost all night and
yet it had been it had been as if he
were not actually there doing it but
never being aware thoughts on something
else perhaps from habit she thought
maybe he's done it so much he decided
it's second nature his body makes the
Motions like mine now as I put these
plates in silver in the sink and then he
wakes up and they begin talking with
each other and she learns about Joe's
story she sees a tattoo asks him what's
that blue letter C is that your wife and
he says Cairo and she thinks wow what an
exotic name for a wife as it turns out
that is the place where they were
engaged in a terrible battle right the
German and Italian Veterans of that
campaign that was their bond the defeat
of the British and Australian Army under
General got at the hands of Rommel and
is Africa core
she finds his possessions and he's got
an iron cross and so they begin to
discuss the war the Ethiopian campaign
that his brothers had participated in
and he tells her some of his story
um he at 13 had been in a fascist Youth
Organization in Milan his hometown later
his brothers joined a crack artillery
battery when World War II began Joe had
been able to join them they fought under
graziani their equipment had been
Dreadful the British had shot them down
even senior officers like rabbits and it
goes on and on and on she asks are your
brothers Still Alive And he says his
brothers have been killed in 44
strangled with wire by British Commandos
the long-range desert Group which had
operated behind axis lines and they talk
about Britain and he says I wish that
they would do to the British what they
did in Africa you know basically
genocide because of all of the the
fighting right and then they begin to
talk about this book The Grasshopper
lies heavy he pulls out the book and he
says to her uh this is very funny you
know what would it be like if the Allies
had won and he begins you know uh
telling her about some of the aspects of
it and then you get to see the
bitterness again in here he says um
you know how it is that England wins
beats the axis in the book he has Italy
betray the axis Italy goes over to the
Allies joins the Anglo-Saxons we all
know the Cowardly Italian Army that Ren
every time they saw the British drinking
vino and happy-go-lucky not made for
fighting this fellow abenson I don't
blame him he writes this fantasy
imagining how the world would be at the
axis has lost how else could they lose
except by Italy being a traitor the
duche he was a clown we all know that
and so you know again we see this well
didn't Italy participate yes but it's a
minor partner compared to the Germans
and the Italians and he's getting her
hooked into this book and it's
possibilities for the world being
differently
and so they're they're sitting there in
the place and discussing a lot of other
matters they're listening to the radio
and he tells her a bit more
uh I've been living under the Nazis I
know what it's like is that just talk to
live 12 13 years longer than that almost
15 years I got to work hard from OT I
work for organization tote since 1947 in
North Africa and the U.S and he says
listen I got the Italian genius for
Earthworks OT gave me a high rating I
was helping design an engineer and he
goes on and talks about Dr toad came by
and said you got big hands that's a big
moment you got good hands that's a big
moment Juliana Dignity of Labor they're
not all they're not talking only words
before them the Nazis everyone looked
down on manual jobs myself too
aristocratic the labor front put an end
to that I seen my own hands for the
first time and he goes on and talks
about how you know great it was and
Juliana says all your Idols they just
came in after hostilities to clear the
rubble build the autobahns right she's
thinking this to herself and then they
come back and talk about the grasshopper
and she says how did you read the book
it's banned and he says well I read it
secretly in the toilet I hid it in a
pillow in fact I read it because it was
banned and he says
it's easy for you people here you live a
safe purposeless life nothing to do
nothing to worry about out of the stream
of events left over from the past right
and she says to him you're killing
yourself with cynicism your Idols got
taken away from you one by one and now
you have nothing to give your love to
and I think that is quite true she's
perceptive about who this person is and
um
a little bit later there you know he
says this is all just empty talk that
we're doing and she says if you feel
that about me why don't you go on what
are you staying here for and then we get
an interesting foreboding
his enigmatic Grimace chilled her
I wish I'd never let him come with me
she thought and now it's too late I
can't get rid of him he's too strong
something terrible is happening she
thought coming out of him and I seem to
be helping him and they go on and
they're they're discussing you know
what would happen the night before and
he says you're scared of men aren't you
it was possible to tell last night only
because I took special care to notice
your wants and she says because you've
gone to bed with so many girls Juliana
said that's what you started to say and
then here we get one of the first
declarations
but I know I'm right listen I'll never
hurt you Juliana on my mother's body I
give you my word I'll be specially
considerate and if you want to make an
issue out of my experience I'll give you
the advantage of that you'll lose your
Jitters I can relax you and improve you
in not much time either you've had just
had bad luck
so as it's going to turn out he is not
going to refrain from hurting her and we
pick up an interesting discussion while
they're driving and while she is reading
this book and they discuss culture and
the Nazis and this is is quite important
he is going to again make some
declarations about how bad the uh Nazi
regime actually is in terms of Music in
terms of uh literature right he says
that then you know
um I'll tell you who a great conductor
was Arturo Toscanini but he was Italian
the Nazis wouldn't let him conduct after
the war because of his politics he's
dead now I don't like that uh you know
we have this Von card John permanent
conductor of the New York Philharmonic
we had to go to concerts by him our work
dorm what I like being a whop you can
guess uh Verity and Puccini all we get
in New York is heavy bombastic Wagner
and or if we have to go every week to
one of those corny U.S Nazi party
dramatic spectacles at Madison Square
Garden with the flags and drums and
trumpets and flickering flame right and
they talk about books and they talk
about other things like that and then
she goes back to reading uh the
grasshopper lies heavy and interestingly
Joe is going to talk about
um how the world
ought to to work he they're talking
about Churchill and he says Churchill
was the one good leader the British had
during the war if they'd retained him
they would have been better off I tell
you a state is no better than its leader
funeral princip principle of leadership
like the Nazis say they're right even
this Robinson has to face that sure the
USA expands economically after winning
the war over Japan because it's got that
huge Market in Asia it's rested from the
Japs but that's not enough it's got no
spirituality not that the British have
they're both plutocracies rule by the
rich if they'd won they'd have thought
all they'd have thought about was making
more money that upper class Robinson
he's wrong there would be no social
reform no welfare Public Works plan the
Anglo-Saxon plutocrats wouldn't have
permitted it and Juliana thinks spoken
like a devout fascist
and then he says listen I'm not an
intellectual fascism has no need of that
what is wanted is the deed Theory
derives from action what our corporate
State demands from us is comprehension
of the social forces of History you see
I tell you I know Juliana all those old
rotten money-run Empires Britain and
France and the USA although the latter
is sort of bastard side shoot not
strictly Empire but money oriented they
had no soul so naturally no future no
growth Nazis a bunch of street thugs I
agree you agree right she had to smile
his Italian mannerisms had overpowered
him in his attempt to drive and make his
speech simultaneously and we go on and
he says you ever read what the duche
wrote inspired beautiful man beautiful
writing explains the underlying
actuality of every event real issue in
war was old versus new money that's why
Nazis drag Jewish question mistakenly
into it versus communal Mass Spirit what
Nazis call The Mineshaft fulkness like
the Soviets commune right only
Communists sneaked in pan Slavic Peter
the Great Empire Ambitions with it made
social reform means for Imperial
Ambitions and Juliana thinks to herself
like Mussolini did exactly and then Joe
says Nazi thuggery a tragedy but change
Always harsh on the loser nothing new
look at previous revolutions such as
French or Cromwell against Irish too
much philosophy and Germanic temperament
too much theater too all those rallies
you never find true fascists talking
only doing like me right and she says
God you've been talking a mile a minute
and he says I am explaining fascists
theory of action and we read she
couldn't answer it was too funny but the
man beside her did not think it was
funny he glowered at her his face red
veins in his forehead became distended
right so this is quite interesting he's
very very committed to a particularly
Italian understanding of fascism saying
that the Germans got things wrong and uh
you know he's he's certainly taking this
to Heart then what else happens during
this drive
he proposes that they actually could
meet Robinson but he lets Juliana sort
of come up with the idea
she says Joe it's only another hundred
miles we could you drive so good it
would be nothing to go on up there
and she says you know why not try all he
could do is send us away so they decide
that they're going to like you know
clean up get some new clothes get a
haircut and then they will go up there
and very interestingly Joe has agreed to
this and he says I'll let you decide all
the details I know you can do it pretty
girl always gets everyone when he sees
what a knockout you are he'll open the
door wide but no monkey business he he
wants to pretend that their husband and
wife but now notice this everything will
be up to you
but it won't just like the I would never
hurt you but he will right so this is
part of the contrast in his character
now in Chapter 13 they actually get
together in uh Denver and Joe you know
they pick out clothes and stuff like
that and then General Gets a Haircut and
he's also dyed his hair blonde and when
she asks them about that uh the you know
he says I'm tired of being a I I
don't want to be cast as a lower class
person in this racial hierarchy I'm
going to be something different but as
we're going to find out he never really
was an Italian to begin with
and Joe announces that so here we see
him changing the story they are going to
go on after they eat dinner
rather than staying there for one or two
or three days like Juliana wants to and
then going on to see Robinson they're
going to go on tonight
it's important that they take off and
you know Juliana is quite disappointed
about this she balks at it it's too late
tonight and and you know she says why so
and he doesn't answer right she says I
don't want to go and see him tonight I'm
not going I don't want to at all even
tomorrow I just want to see the sights
like you promised me
and as she spoke The Dread wants more
reappeared and settled on her chest The
Peculiar blind panic that had scarcely
gone away even in the brightest of
moments with her and he says no no we'll
we'll do it he spoke reasonably and yet
with the Stark deadness as if he were
reciting
these ways in which he talks are very
important
and then what we find is that Joe
threatens Juliana
he actually tells her
put on the dress or I'll kill you
and they begin to spar back and forth
verbally uh he you know she thinks to
herself he fought these British
Commandos but maybe my Judo training can
Prevail and he says I know maybe you can
throw me or maybe not and she says not
throw you maim you permanently I
actually can I lived out on the west
coast the Japs taught me up in Seattle
you go on to Cheyenne if you want to and
leave me here don't try to force you I'm
scared of you and I'll try I'll try to
get you bad if you come at me and he
says oh come on put on the goddamn dress
what's this all about you must be nuts
talking about killing and maiming just
because I want you to hop in the car
after dinner and drive up the Autobahn
with me and see this fellow whose book
you've now notice use the word Autobahn
there and she begins to figure things
out and part of it is the valet service
and you know what's going on with shirts
and he says she says to him how did you
know a new white shirt can't be worn
until it's pressed and she starts
putting it all together she says did you
really have your hair cut and dyed I
think your hair was always blonde and
you were wearing a hairpiece
isn't that so and she says You must be
an SD man posing as an Italian truck
driver you never fought in North Africa
you're supposed to come up here and kill
Robinson isn't that so I guess it is I I
guess I'm pretty dumb and Joe says well
I fought in North Africa but not with
parties artillery battery with the
brandenburgers I was a Vermont Commando
infiltrated British headquarters and she
says is that fountain pen a weapon and
he says no it's a two watt transmitter
and receiver so I can keep in radio
contact and she says you're not Italian
you're a German and then he says Swiss
so he's he's a Swiss Nazi Commando who
now works for the sacred Heights Deans
to the SD right and they even have a
whole folder on abenson as he reveals
this folder says that he's attracted to
the kind of woman that Juliana is right
of sort of vaguely near Eastern dark
hair certain kind of figure and so this
entire thing has been Joe using her to
get to Robinson and Juliana's going to
have a break into mental illness
he's you know trying to offer her pills
and she starts sort of babbling hair
creates bear who removes spots and
nakedness hiding no hide to hung with a
hook the hook from God hair hear her
pill eating probably turpentine acid
right and Joe looks at her and uh says
um you didn't take the pills you're very
sick we can't go I can't take you to
abinson's maybe we'll try tomorrow she
goes into the bathroom again and she
comes out with a razor blade and then
we've got these very interesting
description uh
as she opened the corridor door he
exclaimed grabbed wildly at her whisk it
is awful she said they violate I ought
to know
um and she says let me buy don't bar my
way unless you want a lesson holding the
blade up she went on opening the door
Joe said on the floor hands pressed to
the side of his throat goodbye she said
she goes out naked and the hairdresser
is like oh honey you're so drunk you
better get back in the room so she goes
back in the room starts getting dressed
and Joe says listen you cut my aorta
artery in my neck and she says you got
the words wrong you mean the carroted
and he says if I let go I'll bleed out
in two minutes you know that get me some
kind of help get a doctor an ambulance
do you you understand me did you mean to
okay you call or get someone and she
says I'll think about letting them know
at the desk she packs up and she leaves
and the end of this whole story of Joe
comes in chapter 15 when Juliana is
reading a newspaper
in the downtown business section she
stops at a cigar store and bought two
afternoon newspapers parked at the curb
she searched until she at last found the
item so here is his essentially his
obituary vacation ends in fatal slashing
sought for questioning concerning the
Fatal slashing of her husband in their
Swank rooms at the president Garner
Hotel in Denver Mrs Joe canadella of
Canon City according to the hotel
employees left immediately after what
must have been the tragic climax of a
marital Coral razor blades found in the
room apparently were used by Mrs
kinadella described as dark attractive
well-dressed and slender about 30 to
slash the throat of her husband whose
body was found by Theodore Ferris Hotel
employee who had picked up shirts from
canadella just half an hour earlier and
was returning them as instructed only to
come on the grizzly scene the hotel
suite police said showed signs a
struggle suggesting that a violent
argument had ad Etc et cetera Etc and
very interestingly she reflects oh they
got my name wrong they got both of their
names wrong right because Joe canadella
it clearly isn't Joe canadella he is
this Nazi assassin she's Juliana Frank
and that is where his
story ends how much of what he said did
he actually believe we don't actually
know
we just know what he did say we know the
things that he committed to clearly just
to put Juliana at ease and use her and
he winds up being killed in the process